okay so the boys season 4 trailer is now
out and throughout this video we're
going to be breaking it all down ccxp is
now happening in Brazil and over the
weekend we're getting some very big
first looks that includes this house of
the dragon and Godzilla X Kong which
will'll be dropping tomorrow obviously
I'm going to be covering it all very
excited so make sure you subscribe to
not miss those videos however I just
want to get straight into this and just
to set the groundwork here's where we
left things off season 3 had buter
taking v24 which in the end left with
the dead sentence that's given the man
about 18 months to live and now he's got
to ramp things up to finish his mission
as for homelander he murdered a
starlighter at a protest and since then
he's been gearing up to go on trial now
we know this because of genv which if
you haven't seen what the what the
bloody hell's wrong with you I'm going
to talk about what happens there so if
you don't want spoilers for that then
please skip ahead it's kind of difficult
to talk about where things are with this
if we don't touch upon that but I I'd
rather you experienced all the twist and
turns unspoiled boil down to as spoiler
light as I can get it though that show
had a virus being developed in the
school this attached itself to the Sals
in compound V and in the end it only
targeted soups completely killing them
this could wipe them all out and we
ended with butcher coming across the
experiments just before that we had
homie watching Things fall in place too
after he'd arrived at the school and
apprehended Our Heroes they were going
to take the fall for what it been a
massacre with him watching from v tower
as the messages piled in definitely go
check out that series as I can't
overstate how good it actually is and
yeah you might have to watch that to
understand what's going on here now this
position is sort of where we pick up in
the trailer with homelander again up in
his room this is a similar thing to what
we got with the season 3 trailer with a
lot of the shots mirroring how that
opened up too every time focus is given
a homelanders back I can't help but
think how they've given a lot of focus
to the American flag that's something
that Shon Eric kryp ke's discussed
throughout the seasons and he's gone
into what angles they're Sater rizing in
this one now disclaimer mate I don't
really care about your politics I don't
really care what they are and to be
honest I'm not fully in the loop of how
stuff's going in the US at the moment
unless it's George Santos cuz man said
he produced a Spider-Man Musical on
Broadway and as soon as I heard that I
had a I had a cheeky little look either
way though yeah I'm going to say what
the producers of the show have said so
any Illusions to real life politicians
is from their mouth and not mine keep
keeping it as apolitical as possible but
it's very difficult to do with a boys
the homelander being on trial is to
Loosely be similar to what's happening
with Trump's trial at the moment many
people also took the ending shut of genv
as being a similar smile to Des sanes
and Eric kpy brought him up when talking
about the show he said they're up
against the DeSantis ticket that's part
of the fun of getting into season 4
which we're just figuring out for this
but he's got a crazy ticking clock he's
got so much to do that he hasn't done so
homelander is going all out there while
he's getting scrutinized in the public
eye and it's clear that V are now fully
backing him not only is Cameron Coleman
covering the story in his favor but
we've also got Ashley out here promoting
the hash home free now I think this is
all going to lead us to the White House
which is a big thing that happens in the
comics Homeland ends up creating a soup
Uprising which was somewhat hinted at
during gen B man ended up taking down
the heroes and this was after realizing
that they'd been attacking other soups
the two behind the masso were propped up
as the hero and he's clearly warning
people for his army in the comics he
ended up ding the White House and
killing the them president who was
called Victor Newman in the show we've
of course got Victoria Newman but
they've changed things up beyond the
character's gender Victoria here is also
a soup and she tried to dispose of the
virus during gen V I actually think she
might be the one who helps to get the
heroes out in that but that's just one
big now her campaign with Robert Singer
really mouning up leading her going
right to Washington I feel like she's
there going to be someone that takes
singer out which is something that Vic
also did to the president in the comics
he then got made the country's president
and then homelander ended up killing him
in the end so yeah I kind of feel that's
where things could be going as homie
feels like he's getting more and more
powerful now on the flip side of this we
have buter with the virus which is also
similar to something that he did in the
comics buter found a way to kill all the
soups on Earth by using a specific
frequency that blew off their heads this
is likely what they're going to try and
use the virus for with it being Bud's
Final Act like how it is in the comics
at that point homelander wasn't around
anymore but I can't see how you do this
show without him so instead I think the
virus thing will happen while he's still
alive and will have butcher probably die
from his own ailments after failing to
release it Le I thing anyway now the
show in comics are never one for one and
we have lots of new elements that are
involving Ryan kryp key stated that he's
going to be a big driving force of this
season 2o and as I'm sure you all know
the kid wasn't in the comics either
there were theories during season to
that he might be a vision of soldier boy
but these were all cast out after Jensen
akles came in still though he's actually
his grandson and there are several
versions of soldja boy in the comics so
maybe those few times weren too far off
now I'm such an idiot on it now I wonder
if he's going to take up the mantle from
his dear old Granddad and then you'll
have a father and son Dynamic like
Batman and Damen Wayne you'll also have
buter trying to lead him away from the
do side 2 with kpy comparing the
situation to the sitcom My Two Dads huge
shout outs to kider for compiling some
info about this and talking about every
time he's touched upon it in an
interview they St that crypy views The
Butcher and homelander as parallels
stating he considers their relationship
like Batman in The Joker or homes in
morotti aside from a deep personal
hatred there lies in Intimate
understanding of one another with the
stakes Rising as Ryan grows up the two
men have much more in common than they'd
like to admit crypy stated that the next
season will also largely focus on the
rise of Victorian human Marley gra
sleeping the white White House that can
kill anyone instantly will likely be an
issue for both V and the boys huge shout
outs again to kider for that and we also
know on top of this what the episodes
are going to be called the names are
Department of dirty tricks life among
septics we'll keep the red flag flying
here wisdom of the ages beware the Jabba
walk my son dirty business The Insider
and assassination run all of them are
named after comic issues other then
we'll keep the red flag flying here and
beware the Jabba walk my son now the lad
comes from a poem R the flag comes from
the song Red Flag by Jim Connell
assassination run focuses on the com
before the storm with it setting up
Homeland is rising before everything
falls apart I can see that leaving
things on a Cliff Hanger and then it'll
all ramp up for the events of season 5
on top of this there's also going to be
two new soups added into the mix they
are firecracker and sister Sage but
neither of them appear in the comic so
there's no real predictions for where we
can go but you know what the creative
team always smash it with a new
character so I'm hyped to see what
happens with them when discussing the
pair he said these new soups are
some of the best and craziest ever
written for the boys you are going to
love them and by love them I mean be
absolutely horrified and a tiny bit
nauseous welcome to the family you guys
and Simon pegs also said he's appearing
in four of the episodes and that this is
going to be the craziest season yet on
top of this we also have Jeffrey Dean
Morgan who many thought was going to be
playing the character Tech Knight as you
know that won't be the case face but he
has described his character as making
the show filthier now details in the
trail is that we see V towers still
being reconstructed which we also saw
during points of genv the middle floor
is completely wiped out and that's due
to the Carnage that happened at the end
of season 3 there's also the voice over
talking about them being mythical
Godlike creatures which I think just
kind of riffs on the the ideas that go
along with the Justice League you also
see but a V video and can catch polarity
standing to the left on a poster
polarity was a character that appeared
in gen V and V was basically breaking
his body down similar to what it's doing
here with butcher they also talk over
the top about how all democracies fail
and that's purely because people are
absolutely stupid she says the f word
but I can't not going to say it here but
yeah it just kind of gives the idea of
where they're heading with the series
there's clearly a divide forming between
two sides with both Starlight and
homelanders fans fighting against each
other the elite and those causing the
division they're not really involved and
it kind of speaks to the the general
feeling that a lot of people have about
politics in general you also see my man
checking out an octopus and hey uh keep
just keep it in the bedroom mate and
everything will be fine you might notice
as well that there's a little deep
figure to the right hand side and it
kind of speaks the relationship that
these two are now in now from here we
cut to what I think's a conspiracy
theory Fair as we can see the banner
along the top says there's no
conspiracies or coincidences there's
also a secret revealed soldja boy post
at at which talks about how he's being
held captive by the CIA that's basically
how he left the character in season 3
and it's all unfolding and slowly
starting to come out you might also
notice that mother's milk has an Eric be
and Rakim t-shirt and the character
always wears hip-hop inspired clothing
now from here we cut to French and can
see Jitter Bean Coffee Company boxes to
the right Jitter Bean Coffee is what's
basically the coffee company and the
boys and it's nice to see this just kind
of layer throughout the environment
homelander at this point Compares
himself to Caesar and we see him also
gripping Ryan's hand at this point we
see a girl who's got like some snake
mouths I think it is and yeah she's just
going all out and attacking people with
deadly force the person that she's going
against is Kimo and it shows the kind of
monster level soups that are out there
we also see there's a play on the
Nativity with Queen mave there but she's
being played by an actress everyone at
the moment thinks that Queen mave Is
Dead and I'm guessing that this is sort
of a tribute to her don't know how it
ties in with the Nativity but
potentially they're talking about the
chosen one which homelander could be
propping himself up as you also see that
someone's in the black Noir costume and
though we don't know who replaced him
yeah some's going on here the character
was of course killed by homelander in
season 3 and I am kind of wondering
exactly what's going on because he wears
a mask no one knows who's under it and
thus they can easy cover up homeland's
murder and just put a new person in you
also see someone who's a bit like
multiple man and he pulls himself apart
making duplicates of himself this kind
of reminds me a lot of the thing and the
heads splitting stuff that they did in
that movie Next we see v24 is
overloading in Butcher and it's making
me think he might have Tak even more the
guy's on Bor time as it is so yeah why
wouldn't he just take something if it's
going to give him more Powers you to see
Cameron Coleman and Ashley and she's
clearly doing some some I don't know if
I could say it on YouTube without
getting demonetized but she's doing some
things where she mentions crushing his
balls from here we cut to a train
looking at something in a jar and I
actually think that this might be the
virus might be a reach there but yeah it
just seems very strange and clearly
moving towards him almost like it's
after the V and that ABS up the trailer
and we also know are going to be getting
a big spin-off with the boys Mexico
coming soon there also going to be more
seasons of genv and kpy said that season
4 won't be the end of this either
normally I get a bit worried when they
start announcing 40 different spin-off
shows as you never know if the quality
will still be retained still though genb
gave me Faith and I think they can
probably get away with doing more stuff
that looks so good and season 4 looks
amazing so I'm really hyped to see where
things go next this looks like it's
building off what's come before and
taking things in really big directions
that feel like they're just bouncing
perfectly off the comics obviously let
me know your thoughts below if you agree
or not and if you enjoyed the video then
please hit the Thumbs Up Button if you
want to support us for just 99 cents a
month then please also consider hitting
that join button too you get early
access to videos every week so you can
see our breakdowns before anyone else
huge thank you to everyone who's
supporting us and it helps us stay
independent and keeps our staff happy at
least they tell me that better not be
slagging the boss soft by this b anyway
if you want something else to watch and
please check out our brighten of our
theories for invincible season 2 which
will be linked on screen now that's
coming out in 2024 and I can't wait to
see what Amazon do with it out the way
huge thank you for S to this video and
hopefully I'll see you right over on the
next one just realized I haven't even
introduced myself yet my name is Paul
and if this is your first time here and
thanks for sitting until the end
peace